we got KFC uh we got the bonus banquet
meal mini
fits chips and
gravy there's a chip bang them in there
this was me 10 minutes ago yeah with the
Chick-fil-A yeah but let let's be clear
if it's you and bivo in a race is he
dusting me it dude you think so bivo can
eat like a cartoon really yeah KFC is
banging I was just fancied it I wasn't
even hungry really but why not why not
that's the best that's how to live life
right
there that's that is a fundamental
difference between you and I what I
don't get that feeling what I was hungry
but [__] I [__] fancy it yeah I just
fancy it so why not yeah oh that that's
my life so the new KFC chips they been
not sorted in
something all banging he's just warming
up oh that's banging I needed that I was
craving that big time
B got the chips B got the
chips just wait for it wait till he gets
to that chicken you
heard see I I you know this is Dearing
to me because he shares my like lack of
a lexicon you know for for oh for food
yes yeah did you hear him that what he
just drank a fry he drank it
listen
that that's just him swallowing now he
drank
that and I say that with honor
okay mini fet yeah get in there mini
fillet whip the supercharger sauce cuz
the supercharger sauce is
banging he's only said banging so far
yeah well you know this meal is it is
probably [__] banging no observe he
just bit half this thing okay count
it
that's banging as
well what was that seven bites he just
softened it I don't know I don't know if
I agree man it seems pretty normal to me
I don't know bro I've seen him eat other
things where it's just like really yeah
a Spang okay it's impressive man I like
the way he describes it I got to keep
watching it a little bit yeah no gravy
cuz I got to see how the gravy is what
would you
guess the gravy is I think bivo is going
to say it's
uh kind of a mild mixture a little bit
of pepper a little bit of salt yeah um
I'm translating of course cuz he's
probably going to say sit
sping [__] that looks
good
and not bad damn
it I really thought and he actually did
drink that that time that's what I'm
saying that was like two bites that's
what I'm saying that was kind of
crazy Raw for the supercharger dip over
the gravy but can you imagine all the
KFC taste makers just like watching this
intensely please say banging please say
banging supercharger sauce banging we
got one we got
one everyone everyone quiet gravy's
up it's not bad oh
[__] everyone's on the phones Jeremy
you're
fired Claire call your family you're
finding your
job understand why people get it let's
have one more
taste he's just playing with it so
obnoxious the way he choose he's just
playing with it it really is yeah he's
just playing with
it yeah not bad overall chips 8 out of
10 chicken 8 out of 10 gravy 6 out of 10
big up um big up KFC big up the late
night Munch I'm going to go live right
now make sure to come join big up
yourself
catch you soon big up
bivo big up bivo I love it that's just
normal that's normal guy [__] right
there yeah dinner chip shop Edition
right what we get get Sao is that just
chip and chitty sauce chitty sauce is
that just a loose dog that's a loose dog
I would argue man that's that's that's a
step above a dog you know what is that a
sausage that's that's a performance
piece right
there that's that's um that's that's
regulation only fan size you know what I
mean that's in the terms and conditions
yeah yeah of only fans when you upload
only fans by the way I don't know if you
guys knew this there's actually like
regulation play so it goes through like
a team of moderators no there's just
rules like like basketball there's
regulation size yeah inserts so do they
do do they moderate it before you're
right you're right yes they moderate
before it goes up so they have to they
see if you're within bounds yeah and you
might you know you might get a kickback
and they're like sorry the the
performance piece is not to regulation
standards yeah oh guys my partner
request got denied again
damn live
referee performance
piece not regulation sides going to need
more girth all right let's give these
chips a go cuz sometimes they're good
sometimes they're bad but big up
2023 what like the just the year or is
that the place I assume that the
place maybe or maybe just by coincidence
it's called 2023 maybe no no crispy cod
for the chips Third
Avenue no so I think he just I think he
just liked this year he just biged up
the year wow that's awesome that's
[__] awesome actually that's like
really positive yeah you know yeah big
up 20123 I think it's cuz it's been a a
mega year for him yeah I guess yeah he's
gone viral people know him and maybe he
just touched down to the place and you
know the year's winding down yeah and
he's having this October dog and he's
like big up 2023 yeah I guess my chili
sauce is thick that's
good oh that's good I needed I don't
think you could eat a fry like that dude
three bites three bites I think you're
underestimating underestimating me
dude I You' seen me and then I could
barf it back up yeah and then eat it
again even
faster chips are good the gulp is crazy
holy [__] why is that so
loud no that iPhone microphone man does
he is he wearing a lav yeah that's what
I'm saying like how the [__] he just
putting that right up there ASMR are
10 sausage and but sa why did I say
sausage and but
for
what are you doing man he's giving you a
free show can't do that yeah you ging a
free show bro come on man he knows what
he's doing look at him making eye
contact and everything should we just
leave it here
sure sure yeah
sure this is so
inspiring you see a direction for your
for all your creative Endeavors next
year well I'm just saying like to to
everyone you think yeah like you can
just you're at any point you're like
this close from from you know winning
the jackpot on slots no I'm kidding but
like you're you're like this close to
filming like sitting down filming
yourself doing something normal and
having people find it interesting for
some [__] reason yeah you know you
may never know if the people are
laughing with you or at you but but the
point is you're it's kind of the same
thing now yeah sort of right yeah like
the line is very blurry yeah like people
like you sit down you watch this guy
you're laughing at his gulps yeah cuz he
doesn't really know that he's chewing
weird and yeah swallowing really loud
right but then you're like it's it's
endearing that he doesn't realize that
yeah and he's just trying to rate this
food yeah and know so I'm G to keep
watching him yeah you know shout out
bivo and this guy has rated this chip
shop a number of times that's awesome
yeah that's what I mean
awesome you've cracked the code brother
just saying big up to a year yeah that's
[__]
awesome